i for some reason was wearing swimming
shorts to go to the gym
and they have a fly that's just like a
flap so there's no zip
and i was going commando and it was only
when i got back into the changing room
having finished my
session that i realized i'd like just
the old chap had popped out johnny hacks
for when
you are craving all the chocolate tuna
tuna tuna
what side hustles do you each have like
having a side hustle just suggests that
the main hustle is insufficient
you've done that thing again where
you've put kermit the frog behind you
how many is he behind me again
every whenever i'm recording he just i
think he must live in the bathroom he
must have
oh god right you've done it get rid of
him you've done it again
do you want to make it into the trailer
it's episode 200. two hundy
as if there's been 200 episodes of this
podcast man
how many hours have you spoken on a
podcast chris now
at least 300 probably probably closer to
400 isn't it
maybe not maybe maybe probably about
bang on three i guess
i'm thinking like if you have a the
edited file is the trimmed down version
a lot of the time isn't it or is it not
for you
never never never touch it man never
play around with it but then
with yeah yeah yeah yeah neat neat
it's it's the equivalent of ordering a
steak blue
straight no frills no filters
exactly unfiltered chris that's what it
is man so yes today we are doing episode
200
q a's between my instagram and the
propane instagram account
we have a lot of questions varying
degrees of seriousness
and uh full spectrum really
yeah some truly heartfelt ones and then
some just like would you rather bum your
mum or your dad
i think that spectrum is probably the
word for them um
where should we start with well there's
there's one
how much editing do you do do you ever
cut out parts of the conversation from
jennifer lonz
never ever cut the episode the only
times that that happens is
if there's a connection drop out or if
someone says something
libelous that's like like a
litigating nightmare um which
essentially doesn't happen
i just don't want to what would be an
example you don't have to say what it is
but what what could someone say on a
podcast where someone might get if
someone is
if someone doxed someone if someone said
where someone lived
or whether someone worked or like a
celebrity's real name
or something like that like the email
address or website that someone like
works out of or whatever it might be
have you ever ditched an episode
entirely
uh so in 200 episodes i've got rid of
five
uh added another one to the list the
other week um
which so it's pretty pretty [ __ ] good
like a a two percent
failure rate we've got two out of
250
that's good man i don't know what one of
those is that they were just to spare
the the guests yeah because i just don't
think the guest came across very well
as mine it's it's always like this just
isn't going to add
much to the audience you have faith that
they're going to enjoy
whatever you put out but yeah that was
uh that was good right you got you got
one you got a top
top question good one let's have a look
so
let's ignore tim garrett's sorry tim
that's one for the propane one
um little macdaddy
says what are the best and worst
experiences you've had
and what changed your lives positively
jesus christ
yeah i know it's a bit of a big question
though hasn't it yeah big old question
best and worst experiences yeah these
really are
eggs essential aren't they should we let
that one marinate yeah let's let that
one marinate i've got one here that says
does your tash tickle
uh by sarah jane chamberlain one and
left or your right tactical
[Laughter]
nice nice
that's high brown that's brilliant i'm
i'm having a little bit of
digestive discomfort because we went out
for dinner
last night we stopped eating about 14
hours ago and i'm still
full you did order a lot of food chris
yeah i know but it was our first it was
the first meal we've had in like
four months it was chris's question of
what what does the guinness
would steak award-winning pie come with
and she was like pie and carrots and
you're like
some garlic bread as well please yeah so
it doesn't come with pasta
it doesn't come with a side of pasta
okay
well pizza there's no pizza the rocky
road cheesecake rocky road cheesecake
with rum and raisin
uh ice cream legit this is my worst
experience today
what's that this is a parking penalty
notice
not parking speeding i bet that you're
going to somehow
say it was the fault yeah
no it was my fault like it was a 34 in a
30 zone
is your is a day of your life worth a
hundred pounds yes or no that's the
thing isn't it but it's the
i've been advised because of the premium
insurance i think you still have to
declare it
apparently you no longer need to you
don't declare that you've done a speed
awareness call
that's the risk you're willing to take i
did so i did declare that i'd
done that thing as like i'd put down 30
miles an hour and then put in the note
speed awareness
and it turned out i'd been paying higher
premiums for two years when i didn't
need to so there's a life hack for you
if you've been pop for speeding done the
speed awareness course
it doesn't go on your insurance document
however that is not legal advice and we
are not your solicitor
we are not lawyers when i went on one
there was a guy at the front
who just was just the contrarian who
just answered the obviously the wrong
question and when someone does that
they have to circle back round over the
material and cover it again is that
because he was just
not getting it or he was trying to be a
i think part of it was like
they they asked the question and
everyone in the room apart from one guy
submitted
their answer and they were like because
it's all anonymized and this guy the
front went like
and then you press the wrong button so
it was like i understand
i understand that speeding can be
dangerous 19 out of 20 people
yes i understand one person no i don't
agree right just making the day
slower we go like here we go
that's what you gotta look forward to
man yeah you're gonna hate it we will
check back in once you've done your
speed awareness course we'll check back
in it's fine what i'm going to do
is paint eyelids paint eyes on my
eyelids
[Laughter]
indiana jones style that's love you
isn't it when that happens
that would be that would also be quite
quite enjoyable um
mike o'keefe how you got into club
promoting slash running events
so i was skint during the just after
freshers week
and i sat down next to my then would be
business partner in my first ever
seminar
and we uh i just said man i've spent all
my money in fresher's week and he says i
used to work for this company in leeds
you should come to this thing i can get
get you a job firing
started firing we were flying partners
then became like
a whole managers then event managers
then junior event then senior event then
uh got my first franchise when i was 19
in between first and second year and
that was carnage and it kind of
has just been controlled falling down a
big set of stairs uh
from then so that's kind of how it's
done we've got another one here from
mikey
mckay lag five how can i get rid of my
nihilism
wow well it's a nihilistic question to
want to get rid
of maybe just embrace it
is it i think it's quite proactive and
listen to listen to episode
189 between me and kyle eschenroder
uh working out what do you want to want
in life
that will help to get rid of nihilism
what have you learned from podcasting
fes
festive 96 [ __ ] l
what have you guys learned within the
last month from a podcast
um it's probably the best way
to communicate with an audience i think
i think it's because people listen to
podcasting when they are like doing
something
otherwise quite manual and want
something interesting or
entertaining and so like you usually
have quite a bit of their attention
so as a communication form content that
yeah they would never otherwise
consume and so johnny said the other day
that
podcast is a conversion tool rather than
a traffic tool
and i'm really coming around to that
idea that people
do people see podcasting as a surrogate
for having friends
and it's a way to really build a
relationship with someone who's already
in your audience but because it's not a
very social platform it's not something
that's immediately shareable
it's really for people who are already
aware of you but want to go
into the deepest yeah it's challenging
to grow an audience
on a podcast because it naturally
there's no virality
the short form stuff doesn't there's no
trending on like apple podcasts or on
spotify or whatever which
inevitably makes it hard but yeah you're
right the depth of connection that you
end up getting with people i mean
that latent leverage thing that you guys
see whenever we
whenever you guys come on you always get
tons of people that want to start
working with you because they buy into
the effort that you've put in coming on
to the show and
this sort of stuff and then the launch
of that email list the other week for me
was exactly the same
you've got this latent leverage that's
been in there
um it's the only thing that like of
anything we do is the only thing where
people will
like when you speak to them they
remember something you said on a podcast
like 100 episodes ago they remember like
a private joke or
a comment you made and you don't get we
don't get that on any other
content method so i think it does just
it's a way of almost as yusuf says like
you build you build friendships with
people almost virtually or like people
know a lot about you and you nothing
about them that's a scary thing
it's such an asymmetry which
which like kind of makes you feel a bit
guilty you're kind of a bit like well
can you please record 300 hours of
content and send it to me
so that i can then be as up-to-date on
you as you are on me
then let's move forward so it happens a
lot with my flatmate
where i'll say something like oh yeah i
know i've not told you this but
he's like oh no it was on episode one
two seven of wisdom and
episode 53 of the propane podcast like
right or like i'll come out into the
living room and i hear my voice on
double speed
as i walk past i'm like nice there was
something
there was one one thing that once
happened this was when i was still
working as an accountant when i was
um i sat in a in a bill in a room in
like a presentation
in leeds and i could see someone two
rows in front of me
like get that phone out and then like
close an app and the app was
the broken fitness podcast on on apple
podcast and i was just like
that's so weird you know you just like
yeah yeah exactly please please no no
photos no photos
big glasses and a massive hat on
but it's also the feeling of like when
someone says i've listened to your
podcast i always think like
what about it's almost like someone's
read my read a journal
because you think like something i
thought two months ago i probably really
thought at the time
but i can't really remember what it was
someone who was decorating his house had
said that he'd put
he'd basically create a playlist of
every modern wisdom episode from
one to whatever it was 180
and had just started watching them and
highlighted that
between i think it's episode life hacks
101 and life acts 102
we change t-shirts but the camera
doesn't change position and neither does
the lamp on the table
wow that is an absolute [ __ ] because i
told you guys to bring a change of
clothes so that we could get two
episodes out of one session
but we didn't move enough of the scene
so he was like
ah i just continuity please yeah i just
wondered if uh actually that was
recorded in one session
rather than two i was out holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was 2008 like january 2018
and we did the pilot we did the pilot
episode in uh like
july 2017. must have been the man who
spotted the
the vacuum cleaner on don't [ __ ] with
cats and was like that vacuum cleaner is
manufactured
components are produced in sweden and
they're imported via a chinese
manufacturing company yeah [ __ ]
hellman uh top
three favorite podcasts you've recorded
um
with you guys i think the how to survive
university episode is
wildly underrated that was a banger so
i cannot remember anything of what i
said on that episode
at all do you know what the advantage is
it's all recorded and it's
gonna listen to it just chug your memory
brilliant
you don't even need to remember anything
you see loads of podcasts
always like that connor murphy guy just
live stream your life
and then you'll never need to remember
what you did yeah if you forget where
you put something
doesn't matter just go back to when you
last had it
on the live stream put it up um yeah how
to
how to survive university we've done
here's one thing i've been thinking
i feel like we blew our load pretty
early
on a lot of mint topics like the
relationship series
101 104 was great how to survive
university was great our confidence
episode that me and you did yousef when
johnny was on holiday it was episode 13
and it was yeah that was an old one
amazing episode just two of us
but now it's like orders of magnitude
like a thousand times more people listen
and so if you're listening and you think
you know all of this sounds quite good i
could do with a little bit more junior
news there's [ __ ] tons
in the back catalog so get into the get
into the 20s and the 30s and the 40s and
crack crack some of them out
i mean to be honest if you want more
johnny and yusuf like we do have our own
podcast as well with yes
250 episodes podcasts true one fitness
one business
yes podcast i think my favorite modern
wisdom moment
that i've been on was when
well two things actually
you said just start with baited breath
because he knows it's about him
my favorite bit i i edited into one of
our videos yesterday which i'll mention
in a second
but okay what's yours it's when yousef
talks about how he used to arbitrage
batteries
that's how you know like oh no don't go
to the petrol station come to me i'll
get your good price i'll give you good
price
that's one of them second one is when
yousef told
uh chris and i that his laptop was
was custom made for macbooks oh
yeah that's it yeah and chris and i in
fact i've got a third one and then chris
and i just like
exchanged this glance off camera as you
said was explaining
first out laughing and then you suffered
that like what are you laughing at
what are you laughing at is it the
condoms is it the croissant
um third one was
yusuf's doing you said talking about the
jaw position
in and out in or out yeah
you were like why did we talk about that
we were talking about prognathia and
retrognathia and the surgery required
to to do each one of them so then you go
youssef goes like
like looks at each of us yeah and then
yeah it's because vgd was there with his
high def
5k camera losing it behind the camera
yeah just losing his [ __ ]
that's another element that no one ever
gets to see the fact that behind the
lens
however funny we find something dean
needs to find it equally funny but be
silent
so that's one of my favorite things
about the whole thing yeah it's
what she's doing it's an absolute ninja
as well he manages to just yeah like
well the funniest i'm gonna have to take
my headphones off here to do this but
it's when he does like a
yeah oh yeah
like a ninja warrior style hurdle
overall down to like spinal reflex level
of just it's like a cat you know when
you watch your cat goes slowly down
yeah i think someone recorded a
like an experiment where they lined up
thousands of dominoes
in the hallway and they've got a cat and
a dog
and they filmed it from the other side
where they the cat like traverses the
hallway
and manages to like really carefully
just step over everything
and then the dog just like wades in
[Laughter]
what what did you say was one of your
favorite bits seth what were you talking
so it's the bit that i edited into our
new channel trailer which
is when it's without the sound but
it's what i say when you're in a
nightclub in the toilet you should be
protecting your penis from your hands
and chris went full oh my god
it made me go floppy it made my entire
body go flaccid
it was so funny you should there's
there's an argument to be made that you
should be protecting your penis from
your hands
and it made every part johnny's like
exactly
every bit of me just go totally flaccid
um as well it was just a bit of silence
yeah [ __ ] out um so how survive
university and relationships are both
sick ones with you guys
other episodes i've done recently that
were great kyle eschenroda this
uh how to work out what you want to want
is it's so
good daniel schmacktenberger was insane
as well those are quite deep
great name quite an amazing name uh
what else we got what is your biggest
lesson from 200 podcasts
jesus um
your competitive advantage is determined
by being authentic to who you truly are
no one can beat you up being you
basically that the closer that you are
to being
whatever is most comes most naturally
yeah you need to make yourself better
and
augment your existing capacities but
your particular um
amalgamation of life experiences and
traumas and predispositions and
where you brought up and the fact you're
an only child or someone
that's arab or someone that's got a 300
kilo deadlift or you know what i mean
all of those things like that but they
are they genuinely are the uniqueness
that you have that
is your competitive advantage so i think
that's that's a fairly big one
so that's a big lesson from um the
four-hour
four-hour chef as well where he talks
about
if you're gonna be in the top one
percent of anything or the top 0.1
percent of anything to be able to have
this competitive advantage
that requires such a disproportionate
amount of effort but actually
if instead you're in the top five
percent of four things
you've got this intersection where
you're this unique combination you don't
have to compete with anyone because it's
a total
blue ocean so i like that the only
problem is that a lot of the time
it's hard many
diluting yourself across multiple
different domains that don't enhance
each other actually
end up spreading yourself too thin so
they have to be things that do
like have a some kind of include
desserts and patisserie
and cocktails and food as well
so yeah and like getting to the top five
percent is
you know eighty percent of the work and
then getting to the final
or so it's twenty percent of the work
and getting the final one percent is
eighty percent remaining whereas like
getting to the top
like getting published papers in nature
and like going hard in like academia or
hard in like
competitive swimming or something like
that it's such a grind
and it's required much more sacrifice i
think i i i agree with both of you
that easier to get in the top five
percent but there's an example of like
if you yousef were a top five percent
pastry chef
and you were also like a doctor and had
all these other things like the fact
that you're a pastry chef doesn't really
help anything like all of the other
things don't worry
what i'm talking about this in terms of
is like seo facebook ads content
marketing
and then if you become like a full stack
entrepreneur you're going to have much
more synergy than if you just become
like an absolute
beast seo and nothing else yeah
fair enough uh how did you start your
podcasts and what is
your purpose in the long run uh
just one second my lesson yeah you
didn't ask us a question
sorry i had a lesson all ready to go hit
me and now i was gonna know everyone's
like oh [ __ ] about good job he's got a
really good point here um
just that we speak to a lot of people
who
like don't start something because they
think they're going to be [ __ ] at it
and i think like go and look at go and
listen to
in fact they may not even be on the
internet anymore because they were so
bad but our first podcasts are
horrendous
we've taken them off it was really [ __ ]
yeah
like done on like an old macbook
microphone
um on a like skype i mean he uses skype
to do these sorts of episodes and then
uh and like no editing or anything like
that
and then go and watch chris chris's
first podcast appearance on
our podcast called chris fit
is it
and they compare chris on that episode
of chris now and people are like i'm not
going to start a podcast or
i really want to do a youtube channel
but i can't get some [ __ ] i really want
to do whatever but i'll be [ __ ] i'm not
as good as people who've done 200
episodes but like obviously not
like there's no way to get better at
something like this
without just accepting that you are
going to be
really bad at it in the very beginning
that's a
really fantastic takeaway and the other
thing as well is that
like if you're if you're waiting until
you feel like you're ready you're going
to be waiting forever i know it's a bit
of a cliche like instagram quote thing
but
it is the truth um and
if it's something that you think that
you're going to enjoy you're not going
to lose anything by trying it in any
case
right um we say this all the time like
it can either be in a year's time you
can either have
moved your fitness business online and
have
a load of lessons as a result of that or
in a year's time still be thinking
wouldn't it be a good idea to move my
fitness business online like which is
better in those situations
and like the the market is the best form
of feedback as well so
even if you put stuff out there you
don't think it's great if it takes off
you're obviously doing something right
and if it doesn't you're going to get
feedback as to what
is the better way to go about this like
you must have episodes chris wait the
way you've done them and you must think
like this is going to be
like this is the one and it maybe does
not as good as you expect and then the
opposite
absolutely it's every episode with with
us guys
where i'm like i can get some huge net
ben greenfield or aubry marcus or derek
sivers or something like that and it'll
perform well
but i'll get more messages about a
catch-up episode where
we discuss yusuf's new b day like shut
off a b day or something you know
like that's that's that's what really
sort of seems to resonate with people
and
i don't know it's you can't you
genuinely with content creation you just
haven't got a clue what's going to land
sometimes you've got an inkling oh god
but
like you you've your top watched video
which everyone should go and check out
on the proper fitness youtube channel
um what i learned from six months of
sleeping on the floor or whatever it is
and it's like that's totally
unpredictable
yeah like there's no reason that that
should have done well so yeah
that's a that's a great thing to take
away if you are considering starting a
uh whatever a blog a vlog a youtube
channel a podcast
whatever it might be crack on like just
go and do it and learn
um i think i had one about uh someone
had asked it somewhere down here about
how do i set up or what's the particular
setup
for the podcast um this one
the current setup is two newer led panel
lights
um a logitech c220x webcam
this is a sure sm7b into a cloud lifter
into an audient id14 recording
into garageband then orphonic masters it
like
that's it that's how i make the podcast
but you can make
all of this with the webcam on your
laptop
and a blue yeti which is a hundred quid
and you will get
ninety percent of the quality that you
need if you can sit in front of a big
window
that's it and yeah that's it and well i
what i'm worried about chris is is the
i've got the like we've got all of the
production quality like we've got the
lighting the like and all that sort of
stuff
and we've got the files like produced to
almost like a radio
station standard it's the cost of the
hosting them that i'm
seeing do you think i'm a [ __ ] prick
how much does it cost to put something
on
that's already been recorded
on the internet do you think i'm a
[ __ ]
prick that would be my favorite moment
ever of modern muslim history if we had
that on field
actually the audio had gone wasn't it
um basically we did a live podcast
for a very big radio company a year ago
and got invited in by people that do
this
professionally for a living for decades
because the ceo of that company listens
to the show
and really likes it and one of the guys
asked
uh yeah what what i'd quite like to know
is um
let's say that we've recorded everything
in the studio
we've got we've got the content down
obviously it's mixed and mastered
um and what i want to know is what's the
sort of cost you know
monetarily to the aforementioned um
uh pertaining to the upload of the file
to the distributor of the rss feed
what's the sort of cost uh and yusuf
internally took massive offense to that
question
i i had a bit of an internal hemorrhage
and i had to
see him like you could see him sort of
lean forward as he was coming at the end
of his question
you know is he is he going to fight this
man
like just to clarify so
you're saying you've done all of the
work required
to have a show ready to go and you're
looking to just
also repurpose it online and your
concern
is the hosting cost of 13 pounds a month
as the largest radio station in the uk
have to justify
it to my boss you know we've got hosts
on the internet how much is that going
to cost
you so well 10 maybe 20 months
so do you think i'm a [ __ ] prick
gee that was like if we we three random
guys
have done this i'm sure
you can justify the second team behind
huge radio stations
can also do it uh we have so many to do
we're already half an hour in right
let's let's go
let's go a little bit more quick fight
i'd be interested to know your best
movie
and documentary recommendations so a
movie in a documentary you've watched
recently that you've enjoyed
uh one i've enjoyed is the staircase on
netflix
i was telling you guys about it last
night over dinner pretty good
uh and movie favorite movie of all time
is interstellar
just [ __ ] epic and so good
johnny
uh the pistorius one yeah his
documentary that's pretty good
yeah um favorite movie
recently would be the gentleman
by guy ritchie tremendous film not very
serious
i always say fight club to that but
that's become like the thing to say
isn't it i feel like people say fight
club they don't really know why it's
just because of what brad pitt's really
leaning it and it's got ed norton in so
i'll say fight club
do you think as well like after a little
bit of time it
it diminish it the diminishing returns
because you've watched it so much
and you almost fall out of love with it
so after 10 times of watching anything
just not that good anymore yeah i i've
tried rewatching fight club in the past
like a couple of years and it's
it doesn't i don't get anything out of
it at all which is a real shame
but yeah oscar pistorius on amazon
excuse me i'm the gentleman
cool i've seen about three films in my
life and one of them is fight club
so so i'm not the one i've seen
interstellar actually it was on a first
date um and it was with someone who
actually
also wasn't into films but we both
thought that that was like the thing
that you're supposed to do
is like oh we go to a film three hour
sci-fi
ever it's talking about like space time
and
like some big pretty big topics yeah
yeah
like big themes
another film actually parasite the one i
got i told you guys about
korean the one that's subtitled oh
that's that's on my list
whoa whoa lift that box up again
it looked like you picked up an airpods
probe it did look exactly like that
no it's just my wired ones
what did you just have in your hand
circle background what you just had you
had something in your hand
an airport you've got mirror
phone earphones and
we've we've got this on video just
having a song i think he's having us
just just so you know
i've got this on video and i can go back
and see if you've secretly bought airpod
pros
you definitely see i've secretly got
like a right look
johnny johnny it's fine it's fine we'll
go back and we'll analyze
the everyone that's listening can you
just rewind by about 30 seconds and see
if you have picks up a [ __ ]
if you've bought airpod pros
and not if you've bought them
his connection is going as well he's
pressed he's pressing imagine the hit to
my
oh what he's pressed imagine hit
ego oh you said what happened
you said now now what you've pressed the
button that means that your connection
drops out so that me and johnny can stop
interrogating you about you
oh you've got like a jammer yeah that's
exactly what's happened
it's it's do you know who it is
chickens moving on and so david
mackintosh jr asked um he
elaborated on this in my dms um how to
control phone usage in
uh in physical spaces so distance is one
of them just add friction
so only use your phone when you're
standing up keep your phone outside of
your bedroom sleep with it outside of
your bedroom
um i think do one of you guys use a box
oh it's jordana's that uses a box isn't
it
because i was like jordan what happens
if you need to use your phone when it's
in the box it's like i don't need it
just shout hey siri at the box well if
you have airpods if you have airpods it
doesn't matter
does it um any things that you guys use
to help reduce phone usage
i think just delete apps i know it's a
really obvious one
but like the digital minimalism thing of
like appraise
all of your digital use for what you're
trying to get out of it
decide whether that is the best use of
the thing like if like okay so i want to
be
i want to connect with friends therefore
i need instagram
for example like well is there another
way i could achieve the same thing
without having to
accept the cost of instagram but like
yeah
i'm not great with my phone really i
look at it too much yeah i think i think
everyone does even you yousef who's the
the least sort of turkeys
yes exactly and if it's if you are using
yours and feel like you're using yours
too much
there's kind of no hope for the rest of
us for anyone yeah
um so i'm gonna do a video on this soon
because i there's a game that i got
so i find whenever i'm going through a
bit of a like a dark patch or a stressed
patch in my life
i download this really stupid game on my
phone
it's like a mortal kombat game and
end up just getting completely sucked
into it and it happened during
one year of my like the worst exams in
med school for like a month
and it happened a few months ago as well
and it's one of those games that like
i'm not even a gamer i'm not into that
stuff and it's such a like
stupid like linear like just button mash
the thing
but it taps into all of the little
dopamine buttons and everything and you
know that it's designed not for
not for actually a fun gameplay
experience but just to
be this compulsive thing and
yeah i just had one day i was like [ __ ]
this i wish i had to delete it like i
spent
and cash on grading more souls
and like this is a shock this is a real
show you have to keep doing quests
whenever i'll start
with my girlfriend and like she'll be
like are you doing a quest i'm like
yeah shut up man let's [ __ ]
and so one day i was like right i've got
to delete it deleted it didn't miss it
at all just
like but then the show is downloaded
again when you are
um when you're in a stressful situation
or whatever
well that that's the risk but it shows
that
you know if you missed it then it would
truly be something fulfilling but it's
not it's just really clever engineering
of a
like compulsive game i love the idea
that it's like
that's your vice versa some people some
people
chain smoke sometimes some people are
abusive to their partners
you download a mortal combat game well
so now this is the difficulty anyone
listening
i challenge you and i really don't
recommend this i feel like i'm
recommending like
going off and buying heroin but if you
download that game just be aware
because life is over just mortal kombat
mobile
oh okay so when you i remember youssef
messaged me saying
this is a white this was like a year and
a half ago that he'd been playing on a
game for a long time on his phone
and i was like similar exact similar
reaction like this is strange
like there's been some kind of
disturbance in space
yeah i should listen to this and then he
told me what was it called
you know you know the one i'm talking
about venture capitalist
adventure capitalist adventure
capitalist and he was like johnny you'd
love it you'd love it i was like all
right cool yeah i'll download it
and it got to the point with me where it
was the first thing i did when i woke up
in the morning was i was like i checked
my
like accumulated when i was onto like
quintillions of
of you know what when you when you're
running a burger shop that's pulling in
like a hundred grand a second
and stuff like this and you're like
upgrading the you know you're hiring a
manager to run your burger shops you can
invest in an oil
an oil tank or whatever it is and you're
moving to mars
and all these sorts of things um and
yeah got the point i was like i need to
delete this now
so use another one of those games that
really taps into that isn't it yeah
how to control your emotions and then in
asterisk
asterisks after that it says there are a
lot of deaths happening due to mental
illness
there's some dark questions coming out
here man episode 200. the samaritans
released a study showing that there's no
significant increase in suicides since
covid has
since locked on has happened but that
suicidality is only
you know it's only one measure of mental
health and mental well-being so it may
well be that everyone's mood is
generally dropped
but it's not necessarily increased
suicidal um
i'm not sure i'm not sure that you want
to control your emotions like control
your emotions what that question means
how to control your emotions
is how do i not feel feelings that i
don't want to feel
like you're always going to feel
feelings that you don't want to feel
it's a case of whether or not you have
the equanimity to let them go
so spend some time doing a little bit of
introspective work
and meditate for 15 out of 15 minutes a
day for
a year and within the space of a year
you will be
at least better equipped to deal with
both bad and good emotions you don't
want to fixate you don't want to
suppress that's what equanimity means
um so it's a bit of a woke
sort of answer to it but i'd definitely
say meditation
other stuff make sure you get enough
sunlight stable sleep and wake pattern
have enough
friends around you have a a job that you
care about to make sure you're eating
good food drink enough water like it's
the basic [ __ ]
the stuff that like your mum and dad
tried to get you to do as a kid actually
had a ton of wisdom in it
because they weren't being thrown around
by the newest trend in personal
development
they only had like the basic the most
basic
plan like the light version
personal development light basic free
with it with no discount code on it and
that's what they were
running on and that's what they had left
so it's like just stick to their stuff
uh which of your failures i have some
thoughts on that chris
hit me i'm trying to get through these i
know it's because all of the questions
are good and we want to delve into them
but this will be a five-hour podcast if
we're not
um so i would i think similar to what
you just said so i think whenever i
and similar to what you just said
whenever i have like mood
a decrease in mood it's always when i am
like my sleep isn't very good my diet's
not very good i'm not
like my step counts lower i've not been
training as often i'm on my phone a lot
so like just manage the like the bait
like give yourself the best
chance of not like just being in a
mood and then you're more likely to as
you say like have more equanimity when a
negative thought does arise or when a
negative feeling does arise
and then something i'm doing at the
moment is um
tracking what i do every hour for a week
to look at
i'm tracking my like how stressed i feel
how focused i feel
in my mood to try and spot like because
i think a lot of the time
when you feel certain ways you are doing
certain things or have just done a
certain thing and you don't really
spot the correlations in your times
you're like oh look like [ __ ] like
whenever i
do this in the morning i feel [ __ ] for
two hours has anything come up
not so far like i'm mainly doing it to
because we've just brought someone on
into the team at propane so i'm i'm more
looking at like what am i wasting my
time doing
what's that chris i'm just so i'm i told
you over dinner last night man like i
was so gassed for you guys to finally
have someone
like you you for everyone that's
listening johnny and yosef have
trolled through the sludge of online
business
for a decade and have kind of pieced
together doing
it'd be like me still handing out
every flyer for all of my events
scheduling
every social media post doing the
accounts standing on the front door
taking the money at the till
also djing and making the music happen
whilst cleaning the glasses
and serving the drinks like you guys
have done top to bottom it's just
awesome to
to see you um scale that up a little bit
more not that you haven't tried before
but i think you've you've encountered
challenges
and i think as well from from a just
from like a teaching standpoint for your
business clients i think that this is
going to be a really important
step that you're then going to be able
to iterate on and teach other people to
do
because you have down
how to start a fitness business and then
scale it
but how do you then start to relinquish
that amount of scaling to
delegate that out and i think this will
be like the next stage for the business
clients that you have got
who really really want to go to the next
level i think you're learning over the
next year or two years maybe
will be like the pro huge penis like
swollen swollen version of your program
yeah so we've always had like people who
work for us part-time in various
capacities like people who do specific
things
but this is our first like full-time
full-time person so which comes with
apprehension obviously and all sorts of
things but but yeah so that's why i'm
doing it but
um you spot like oh certain things so
like
um yesterday for example you guys will
be happy about this like i was
like focus was dropping like stress was
like background
went to dinner and just immediate like
stress like
notice of like feelings of stress and
feelings of happiness just went like
so like you're like okay like as i
already knew as you said chris like
spending time with friends is just an
immediate like hard reset like you come
back from that experience feeling
like whatever you're worried about
before doesn't exist so there's i think
it's the book
called karma what it's called but you
like make a happiness buffet
it's like 10 things you can do or like
things that i know when i do one of the
following 10 things
it almost always boosts my mood it
almost always makes me feel more
positive
and if you become aware of those things
and you can like draw on them when
you do you want to feel better let's go
and have a cold shower let's go for a 15
minute walk let's have a big glass of
water let's go and play
i was telling you last night about how
much joy i'm getting from
playing catch up against the wall with a
tennis ball my pomodoro breaks
yeah it's such a stupid dumb childish
thing
but it just brings me like pure
happiness for five minutes
ten points yeah easy um
which of your failures would you say has
resulted in the most
future successes bloody hell um
i don't know it why don't we do why
don't we each answer so like
seth if you want to answer one then
johnny will answer one cause there's
like
hundreds of questions here um any
failures that have come up
that have resulted in the most future
successes for any of you guys
yeah so i i tweeted about this the other
day and had some interesting discussions
with some people
about do you agree with the idea that
you should never have regrets there's
always people that say oh you should
never have it
now yes in principle that's a nice idea
but there are many decisions that you
could take which move you
in one direction or another purely by
chance and it's not that the decision
was necessarily good or bad it just
happened to turn out
fortuitously or badly now
if that's the case then yes you kind of
regret the fact that it turned out that
way but the decision was kind of neither
here nor there
with things that you chose you actively
decided to do and it turned out badly
and you've learned a lesson from it
as long as you learn the lesson then i
would see that as you're paying tuition
to
the world and the quickest way to
or the most direct example of that is in
trading
so like forex trading for example where
if you make a big loss
as long as you learn from that and learn
how to adapt your strategy that is your
tuition to the market
and so yes it might have cost you five
grand or 23
grand in my case but it's it's a very
valuable lesson
because you've you've then been able to
be like okay
there is where i went wrong and i know
that i'm not gonna
do this again and it's probably more
effective than if you just read about
someone else doing it because you've
like physically experienced your anus
being torn apart by the market
as a result so that's what i would say
well there's that quote from um i think
it's peter thiel who says um
any idiot can learn from experience i
prefer to learn from the experience of
others
but the problem with that is that you
don't ever have the
visceral contextual sting yeah
like looking at someone else's gaping
flappy [ __ ] does not have the same
impact
come from it doesn't have the same
impact as it being your [ __ ]
um and it um you can go back in time
to one year of your life and share
current wisdom which one and why
2012 start podcast chris there you go
now you
like one of the biggest podcasters on
the planet because first mover advantage
um what do you do
if you feel like you actually don't know
what you want from life
johnny
if you feel like you act like you
actually don't know what you want from
life directionless meaninglessness
purposelessness
i mean some people approach this as like
you should work out what your values are
and then make goals based on your values
and all that sort of stuff
i the thing that was most helpful for me
in terms of like
why i like quit my job and why i'm like
doing what i do now
is i actually did an exercise from a pdf
download from a guy called nate green
back in like 2010 um which was called
the heroes handbook
nate green's a really good writer if
anyone wants to like go and read more on
sort of like
pop philosophy and sort of just like
general very simple ideas of how to
preview your life but anyway
it was just literally and you probably
heard this before design
like think of the best possible day you
can imagine
from start to finish like where do you
wake up what's the room like what are
you doing that morning what are you
doing at lunch time what does the
afternoon look like what are your
evening plans
and then expand that in like a night
like the best week you can imagine
and then think right well how can i
begin to move my life towards that and
from that you extract
like there's goals from that that you
can create and it is
it is pretty cool how um not to say like
look at me but it is pretty cool that
like i'm pretty close to that
like at the time i was a mile away from
it and i you couldn't see
you can't even think like how would i
how can i figure that out like
surely i would never be able to build a
business and live off it surely i'd be
never be able that happened on the
internet
that [ __ ] doesn't work all these
sorts of things um and then
like you look back on it a year later
and you're like [ __ ]
like i'm making progress towards that so
i think that's the thing that um
what is he called
right to wait but why tim not tim urban
yeah yeah so he talks about like
happiness being crushing a tuesday
on the interview he does with tim
ferriss so like the idea that people
worry about goals and what they want and
all that sort of stuff and forget that
like ultimately
tomorrow you're just going to wake up
and it's just going to be a day and
you're just going to experience a
sequence of those and then
cease to exist so if you just think
about like well how can i make
my day or my week the best possible or
like maximize my
my experience of existence as possible
probably
you'll be quite content and feel like
you're moving the right direction i
think
to sort of add on to that a lot of the
time because there's so much urgent
stuff that we do
we don't ever actually sit back to get
into planning mode
we're just constantly in dealing with
mode and it's that system one system two
thinking
um that you need to step into and that's
what i realized especially with lockdown
because i got more time
away from having to do the club stuff
which allowed me for the first
couple of weeks or even actually first
few months of lockdown i went through
like
tons of chris sparks experimentation
without limits or whatever it's called
i went through that i started using
things three and completely tiago
forte's getting get stuff done like a
boss
course uh did like loads of stuff added
in a bunch of habits but you can't ever
do that when you're constantly fighting
fires within your own life
so it's like i think a lot of people
that don't necessarily know what they
want from life
haven't ever taken time away from
life to ask that question it's like if
all that you're always doing is being
busy
saying yes to social events saying yes
to more
stuff projects businesses things for
your boss
nights out all that sort of stuff like
you're not ever going to it's not just
going to emerge
if you don't have it if you haven't
stumbled upon it by chance it's not just
going to emerge
you have to actually do the work you
have to spend the time
consciously thinking what would a good
day week
month five year 10-year 25-year plan
look like what would i actually want
and then it's like where am i trending
like am i trending in the right
direction or the wrong direction like if
i keep doing what i'm doing now for 10
years
where will that leave me is that a good
situation or a bad situation and then
adjust
but i feel like you just got something
to say quiet the mind and the spirit
will speak
like if you're firefighting the whole
time
your voice for inner intuition and your
existential questions are just
muffled because you're dealing with all
the
the crap day-to-day so yeah you have to
create some space
someone told me recently it might have
been one of you two that every good idea
they've ever had in business has been
from going on a walk
was it one of you two maybe not we were
talking about some
ideas in the shower the other day
weren't we the notebook
yeah brief notebook in the shower yeah
so writing things down while you met it
like things always come to me while i'm
meditating but like yeah walking
somewhat someone's i wish i could
remember who it was
it's like they go for a walk in the
morning and that's when like all of that
and there's something about like being
in motion
and the thought processes that happen
when you're when you're moving um
but that just the the quiet the mic so
like if you walk without any podcast or
anything in suddenly all this [ __ ] just
occurs to you i loved um
it was a life hack from a while ago
drive without any music or podcast on
like if you just go on a drive to work
like once a week if you pick
wednesday as your day where you drive to
work without any content playing
it's so nice like you just get to sit
with your thoughts for a bit of time
without the input of other minds and
that's this
definition of solitude by cal newport
right solitude is time
uh on your own away from the input of
other minds
not just time on your own on the phone
listening to a podcast
reading even that you know so yeah
uh what else we got gyms or restaurants
you can only save one from the
coronavirus yusef
james easily like
how i mean how often do you go to a
restaurant compared compared to
like number of hours you spent in the
gym the alternative argument is
keep restaurants open buy a home gym
best of both worlds
but i'm an anti-social bastard like i i
prefer to be
training away from people and in silence
great great um nick purvis a guy that
runs candy candypants
podcast which is great and everyone
should go and check out how do you
balance
the constant desire for self-improvement
without being sucked into a perpetual
cycle
of feeling like whatever you do is never
enough to [ __ ]
great question that mate um so the line
between
being tough on yourself to continue to
motivate you to do
more and being easy enough on yourself
to know when you've worked hard is a lot
wider than you think
i think a lot of people self-flagellate
out of some feeling that
it's going to motivate them to do more
the next time whereas that's actually
not
necessarily the way it works you need to
treat yourself
as if you're someone you're responsible
for helping you need to be a friend to
yourself you wouldn't be this way to a
friend
there's this song that i'm loving at the
moment which is
one of the lyrics says um
it's gone lyric's gone so i'm not gonna
be able to tell you what it is but i'll
put it in this
is the lyric it's parasite eve
this is the moment you've been waiting
for that's it i thought that might be
what it was
that's what it is um it's just it's it's
hard man like
you know if you want more out of life it
is very very challenging to not
constantly just feel like everything
that you do isn't enough
i think having a very
strict quantified metric of your to-do
list
hard stop and work cycles helps that a
lot
because if you're never any ongoing
project
is always going to be you can always do
more work
whereas if you set yourself okay if i
have this much
work to be done this day and i do it
then you stop working and it gives you a
sense of accomplishment
but as everyone that's got an ongoing
project knows
like it's it's never finished it's
technically never finished so you have
to create these arbitrary
done lines that
give you some sort of a feeling that
you've finished it so um
yeah what else we got uh
someone's just written rogan as a
question
don't know uh well we discussed that in
the last episode didn't we
the spotify rogan yeah situation uh
johnny any tips for becoming a better
writer
struggling with essay writing for med
school i'm gonna pivot that to yusuf
essay writing for med school so i assume
that's someone who's going to who goes
to cambridge then because that's
spiral tag if it's essay writing to get
into med school
then realize that your personal
statement will not even be read by the
admission staff and
everything hinges on the uk card score
which they don't tell you and it's a
basically an iq test that they claim
is socioeconomically blind but it's not
because it's very much favors men from
a white men from a private education
background but luckily you can reverse
engineer the process
do what i did i increased my score from
six nine
six four five to seven nine five so i
increased my
iq supposedly by 1.5 standard deviations
um which is not that's not obviously
possible but
it's just the fact that you can just
hack the the system
so awesome so ignore essay writing if
you go into med school it's not a skill
that you need
focus on the admission criteria that
matter
that's an example of the scoby stream
well do you know what another example of
the scoby stream is
youssif's connection was a little bit
dodgy before so i messaged him on
imessage on desktop saying can you check
your internet connection
and all that he's replied with is 89 144
megabytes per second
what's 89 what's the percentage that's
the signal strength
strength probably yeah actually that's a
good life hack wi-fi signal it's a menu
bar app that tells you your
connection speed in real time johnny
hacks for when
you are craving all the chocolate
tuna tuna tuna
chocolate tuna isn't tuna i'm used to
know the answer to this
isn't hasn't tuna got the same thing in
or the same
something mercury well there's a lot of
mercury in chocolate i hope not
because anthony tony robbins johnny
doesn't like it when i say anthony
robbins it just sounds like he's your
uncle or something
good old uncle tony um had got mercury
poisoning from eating swordfish every
day
for some reason he decided to do that
and he said he started to get like
um psychiatric symptoms from it and when
he stopped
it went away geez
do you know i don't know about tuna and
chocolate cravings i'll have to look
that up do 20 push-ups
20 push-ups will stop you from feeling
hungry um how do you find
people interested in talking and
debating
the topics you cover same for you guys
like where do you find your podcast
guests from
we just have people that we find
we want to talk to anyway people that
we're interested in having a chat with
and i think it's the same with eucharist
isn't it
yeah just on the internet existing on
the internet or reading books or
listening to podcasts
i think it's a bigger question which is
why do you want to start a podcast
and then is this about podcasts how do
you find
people interested in talking and
debating the topics you cover
i think it's like how do you find guests
so we we
the way we pick our guests is like who
is the
who who is listening to the podcast who
is most relevant to that person who
might they find interesting
what can we talk to them about so like
we've had on the fitness podcast like
everything from
like kit lachlan who's like talking
about a very specific aspect of
like stretching meditation all the way
through to like power lifters and you
know it's it's like what might that
audience be trusted and that's just the
framework really
who uh i don't think i've ever asked you
this who
would be a dream guest to get on the
propane business podcast
from a like insight
perspective time for us
tim ferriss insight not quite
so don't don't be asked about clout not
bothered about asking them questions yes
who would you want to learn from the
most on the propane business podcast
jeff bezos really like jeff bezos
warren buffett um
yeah any billionaire elon musk or tim
ferriss
youssef yeah that's pretty good answer
tim's
tim's a great show he's i think he's
having a bit of a bad time at the moment
man he's back on antidepressants and
he's running a lot of ads he's running
about paid traffic
you'd know wouldn't you because you've
got here's a you've got you've got the
plugin that tells you when tim turns ads
on
yeah it's just just a light that turns
on the corner
something i sent to yousef actually he's
got an ad running at the moment for
um 17 questions that changed my life to
download pdf it is absolutely brilliant
okay so if you see an ad from tim
ferriss on on instagram or whatever
swipe up on it and get that he's got
like when you click on it there's like
five downloads one of those like five
morning routines to win the day
17 questions to change my iphone about
fear setting
legal just lead magnets yeah just pdfs
yeah cool
um how would you distinguish fact from
fallacy in an area completely unknown to
you
just just ruthlessly use mental models
hanlon's razer
occam's razor mcgill's razor and if it
if it breaks any of them [ __ ] it off
that's it
we were talking about this yesterday
which is that whenever you see
a news article and it happens to be on a
topic that you actually have some
specialist knowledge about
and you're like this is [ __ ] like
come on x daily express or sun or
whatever like this is complete
and then you're like oh maybe all topics
are like this
for things that i don't know about so i
think that's look at
such a scary inside man it really
[ __ ] so wow
so it's like look at the providence and
think like okay
is this a source that has some and if
you don't know what metrics to actually
um measure something against then
it's probably quicker and faster rather
than trying to use your own [ __ ]
filter is to pick someone who has the
specialist knowledge in that and ask
them for some recommended
sources of information and use that but
because of how
like the information in any area is
spread it's almost a certainty
that the common commonly held belief in
that area is incorrect
yeah so if you just assume that the
major the common opinion is incorrect
and wrong
and look for like look for the
contrarians in the market like look for
the polarity in the market and then
listen to those people then form your
own view in fact
yeah um podcast how-to logistics
software mic headphone production
already gone through that uh top three
guests kind of already gone through that
who stood you up last week
uh that was michael matzola
the director of unacknowledged dr
stephen griez ufo documentary
um he is maybe he's been abducted
because he didn't [ __ ] reply
um do you take any protein supplements
johnny not really
you used to back in the day i've i've
got some but i'm not
very religious with taking this you were
like missed away
i was
yeah it's a it's a much more convenient
way of taking protein in and i
just see it as part of diet i don't
really it's just a continuum
of different food types rather than a
supplement per se or
yeah but i haven't got room based on
what i'm eating at the moment
i've got 205 grams of protein that's
just
flat at all times and i i don't have
room for a
protein shake in that you eat a lot of
yogurt don't you which is basically a
protein supplement
i can't pronounce it which is white
no it's not
it's not that it's spell it chris it's
so it's a steve jobs new type of quark
which is white chocolate flavor i put it
on my instagram the other day
it's unbelievable and um
the i put the i put the macros up on it
a pot of it
17 grams of protein four grams of carbs
0.5 grams of fat fine
sold amazing can i get it do i have to
get it from a supermarket or like could
i get like a big
like job lot on a pallet delivered uh
it's
only got about a month month and a bit
of
expiry so i'd be it's fantastic yeah
that's the great thing about dairy
isn't it you get loads of cheese and
yogurt and you don't need to worry about
it going update
yeah mint um if you had to tell someone
to watch one modern wisdom podcast what
would it be and why
life hacks 201 was [ __ ] brilliant
start the second series my life hacks
was just i think all the lifx episodes
are like such an easy intro into what's
going on it's a nice balance between
just sort of
quick pace stuff and banter and you can
always take something away and
um favorite anjuna deep set was the
episode 200 i think by james grant
that's from jack revel i know that
you've been on his uh live stream
recently um everyone needs to listen to
one junior deep if you need some music
to work to their podcast is
fur nominal mark dobson what's next for
modern wisdom how far ahead do you plan
uh where do you see it in a year's time
so next big thing is this modern wisdom
academy which is going to be the summary
service
i'm like just so so [ __ ] excited for
that i think it's an amazing
project and it's going to mean that no
one ever forgets what they hear again
um how far ahead do i plan in terms of
scheduling about a month and a half
so i'm booked out this is recording this
at the start of july i'm booked out
until the middle of august
um i need to stop publishing three a
week
i know that that might make some people
sad but it's like it's unsustainable
for a very very long amount of time it's
just so much work
uh and where do you see in a year's time
i don't know man we did
over half a million plays last month in
june um
so if the growth keeps on going then
it'll be i don't care it's just more of
the same like keep finding interesting
people keep talking to them
keep having you guys on hopefully not
have to do this over skype
like um oh did i tell you that i got my
sofa re-cushioned have i told you about
this
that is exciting i think you mentioned
it yeah so i
got a buddy it will be so if you want
this service it will be linked in the
show notes below because it's [ __ ]
amazing and i
cannot believe elliot flack has created
this new company
where you send off the cushion covers
from your couch and then they use the
covers
to make a mold then create a special
perfectly fitted new cushion for each of
the different covers that you've got
and then send back however many you need
for each so i got four bases two backs
two corners one footstool thing and now
i have a brand new set of cushions on my
sofa perfectly fitted
and it looks like a new sofa it's
[ __ ] amazing
it goes from being like a saggy old like
you love your sofa but you don't
you don't you're like ah maybe the
cushions don't fit so good and
uh it's outrageous like ridiculous
service and he turns it around in like a
week
i couldn't believe it that's phenomenal
um
are you got any good questions on your
guys's side any cool stuff
uh what side hustles do you each have
god yes if i want to know this [ __ ]
hell how long have you got
he's still doing the battery thing yeah
still arbitraging batteries yeah
um hold on so hold on are you really no
no no right um it says everything
that you had to check well because when
he told us about this i remember
chris's reaction was like so that's what
he was doing last weekend he wasn't
really busy with
his girlfriend he was like down in the
flat the factory in slough
and making sure the supply chain was
still working it wouldn't surprise me
yeah so no i i my only side hustles is
i'm i'm
trying to get a rental property
currently i have a side hustle as a
doctor
and um we do
and we do propane propane business
propane fitness and propane business
the fitness uh plus you trade
what's up trading riding oh yeah trading
of course
i mean i i see trading as a capital
growth strategy rather than an income
strategy but
you're right it should be included in
the no one's gonna be like oh well your
side hustle should technically be
yeah like let's include that johnny
uh none i think you should just have
one main thing all in yeah and hope for
the best
like having a side hustle just suggests
that the main hustle
is insufficient which is the that's the
problem so focus on the primary hustle
being everything you needed to be would
you not agree that multiple revenue
streams is a safer way to
you can diversify your revenue streams
within the hustle
you don't need to diversify revenue
streams within on a macro sense
necessarily
didn't you do a very expensive very long
trading course
i did yes i've not used it though
it's nice to know that it's right it's
nice to know
what you thought you didn't know and
that now you know and finally
that lex needs to be here well he
depends on what you class as well as
as a hustle like a form of work of time
for money or
what is a investment strategy and you
know most of them can be pretty passive
especially property when you can
just get everything managed and leave it
to the experts
i had to pay a significant amount of
money this morning
to newcastle city council for that
selective licensing thing that i warned
you about
awful i got an email as we arrived at
dinner last night literally as i got out
the car to say hi to ben
and got an email that said by midday
tomorrow you need to pay us
two 000 pounds so that we can process
your license like
don't email that on a [ __ ] friday
night
don't tell me that you need to give me 2
000 pounds within like
15 hours or else a bad thing is going to
happen
that's just a [ __ ] wait to start the
weekend
terrible way to start the weekend uh the
frugal heart concept what are some
little things that make you stupidly
happy
um that's a throwback to the kaialeshan
rhoda episode from the other day
throwing a tennis ball against the wall
frisbee and boomerang
are both like throwing anything little
children
dogs um i think it's got to be something
you can also easily catch
makes steel mace um
you should have started doing like
weighted club training
it's all over our instagram yeah it's
just good taking it really seriously
it's like film mobility like low body
hypertrophy
great johnny here's one for you what are
your experiences with peds slash psalms
if any
nada completely tested federations bro
we you have shared a photo the other day
of a guy who got really
cross with us so we we for a long time
shared this article which was how we got
lean while eating haribo cheesecake and
pringles
and it just upset every personal trainer
who was like the only way you can do
this is by like
lying or being on loads of drugs or and
then this guy like got really aggressive
and accused us of
accused like youssef who's in a lot of
the photos he's like 74 kilos
in the photos of being full of full of
drugs it's like we are both at the time
we were both like sub
90 kilos the 200 pound rule is i think
mark bell has a 200 pound rule that like
anyone
anyone abs lean over 200 pounds
fine and is like he just stands there
and goes find me an exception in that
rule
and it's pretty hard
[Music]
fair enough uh how long have you been
sober now 22 months
which is a lot longer than i'd planned
it was only going to be 18.
uh not a question stumbled across the
podcast in lockdown great work thank you
marty kimbo
how you met johnny and you
seth y o usef uh from sam um
through my housemate then who was your
guy's old business partner ben tommy
um and that was it
so you crack each other's backs and uh
another first sight and thought
[ __ ] gonna be mates with them that um
one favorite podcast each from you guys
that isn't
mine or yours
tim ferriss is just pretty good to be
honest new
tools of titans thing that he's doing uh
i've i'm halfway through one of them
very good as well i think it's just the
audiobook of the
but he's put it onto podcasties now
hasn't so clever he manages to really
squeeze the lemon out of all of his
books
and just like well i feel like he made a
podcast and then he's made two books
from the podcast and now he's doing a
podcast of the books that's from the
podcast
so impressive and then there's like
youtube content based on the books from
the podcast
like that man um well i'm having a look
at my
podcast subscription for me to be honest
i feel like it's a boring answer for me
to give so let's see
i listened to a lot of like very like
specific business things that probably
wouldn't be interesting
um so there's a guy called dan sullivan
who runs a business called strategic
coach that he's
he's got a really good podcast each
episode's like like
thought processes for for business
owners um
digital marketer podcast pretty good for
anyone who likes digital marketing
london reel podcasts really
i'm joking i'm joking although it is on
my list
uh the whoop podcast pretty good
actually as well
is it yeah well ahmed's got good reach
the ceo's got like [ __ ] good access
to people
um yes anything from you
so actually from looking at my podcast
subscriptions
it seems like i'm i'm more listen to
specific episodes from
a variety of thingies rather than a
single source
yeah it's interesting yeah i don't think
i think that's very rare
in the podcasting world i think most
people put their faith into a host or a
show
and then just allow that because you
can't you can't
really listen to unless you're doing it
your way in
specifically yeah exactly like
fishing line goes out and then you find
the thing and whatever
like you it's too effortful to go i'm
gonna have
that guy's on this podcast he'll be
interested and they'll be interested in
i think i'm very lucky that i've got
friends that are really into
various podcasts and they kind of curate
and send me single episodes and so let's
just go
can we pull back from the brink from sam
harris yeah
no oh mate it's
the most sentimental case in point here
the most sense making that you're ever
going to see around what's happened this
year
can we pull back from the brink yeah
[ __ ] phenomenal um do you have a list
of all the books you have read so far
yes at amazon.com sorry amazon.com
modern wisdom go and see everything
being alcohol-free seven months equals
friends involving me less
because i don't drink [ __ ] these friends
off or show them that i don't need
alcohol to enjoy myself
it's tough when you have no close
friends that are on a similar wavelength
[ __ ] good question man meaningful
question
uh there's this quote from james clear
where he says um shared values and
expectations
uh dictate behaviors within the tribe
often changing your behavior
behaviors requires you to change your
tribe and
that's just if your friends are only
friends with you when you're getting
yourself pissed and destroying yourself
along with them then
you need better friends like they're
supposed to be supportive of you
no matter what you're doing and if the
only time that they're prepared for you
to be a part of it is if you're drinking
the same stuff that they're drinking
they're not really that good mates
but that they denominator between you
there is the fact that you drink the
same drink
i'm [ __ ] hell like that's like you
saying that you go for a drink like go
go on a day out with your dog because
that that also drinks water like that's
there's not
a very high bar to set um
when did you actually start reading so
much and get interested in personal
development
has it always been that way for you
yusuf have you always sort of been an
introspective sort of because for me it
wasn't maybe until my late 20s like
maybe 26 or 27.
the yeah there was no dramatic moment
for me where i was like i need to kind
of question
things and um but it's been like a slow
burner and it's
it's accelerated over the last 15 years
um
i do know many people that have just
been like
flat and then suddenly just gone balls
in on it which is really interesting and
i i'm so fascinated by what is that
precipitating moment
that causes someone to just go like i've
been a waste man for the last 10 years
right i'm gonna
completely change direction it was it
was fitness for me i think
it was being overweight as a kid and
then you're like right i need to get a
handle on this
and then before you know it you're sort
of like reading
things or like i i can remember
listening to podcasts when
like the way you would listen to a
podcast on your phone in some instances
was
you had to like go on to the like the
web hosted file and play it on like the
native player
on the web page on the web page and it
was really like jerky
and the audio was terrible um and there
was something called the fit cast
where this guy had i think it's called
kevin i can't remember his name
but the fit cast was like one of the
first podcasts in the fitness industry
he had loads of people on there
and through that podcast i was
introduced to loads of different people
and then you hear about these things
like you hear about tim ferriss and then
he introduces you to loads of people and
you suddenly become aware of all these
things
i think that's how that's certainly how
it started for me and probably how it's
still
going for me i like to access someone's
world and then
they introduce you to five new people
who introduce you to five new people and
i don't know many people that tumble
down the rabbit hole of new
creators as effectively as you do
like you just what do you mean just so
johnny will
stumble on someone i don't know whether
it's because you have
this you you do tend to kind of listen
to people like tim
who inevitably have quite a dispersed
guest
um influx but then you you do sometimes
like [ __ ]
i know some ovens is not like um
underground but like you've gone very
very in to him right and he's hardly the
people who johnny follows as well
like like nikki's mitch and sam evans
and all the they're all they're
very like they don't have mass appeal
yeah for people outside of that niche at
all
well that's that's just the thing that i
always talk about which is like i'm
always looking for
what is the what is the bottleneck and
how do i how do i fix it and who can i
follow or listen to who has the answers
to that bottleneck so that you end up
like listening to
some really weird [ __ ] frankly being
like a
um my sleep quality is atrocious any
tips
on improving this area in general please
from benny had
yousef what's the what's your top line
sleep tips top line sleep tip so
chris is a big proponent of sleeping
with your phone outside your room i
think
most people can't rely on the motivation
or willpower
or immediately i'm waking to to kind of
start not playing with their phone
immediately and tanking the first half
hour of the day
and i think how you treat your morning
and how you treat your evening are
really important
stop caffeine i have definitely seen
both ends of the caffeine spectrum
when i was working in finance i was 800
milligrams a day which is equivalent to
kind of ten
cups of coffee uh eventually just from
caffeine pills
and i was just propping myself up i was
like you know that darling painting
where there's like
there's a cloth like a wet cloth that's
all got holes in it's just held up by
sticks and it's just like
like that was me just with caffeine
then i went cold turkey for a few years
on reintroducing caffeine
started falling asleep during the day
which i'd never had done
previously and i think this is just
because caffeine has such a long
half-life
10 hours or more for it to just be half
the level in your system
that it will absolutely affect your
sleep quality and you always get these
hard bastards that are oh no it doesn't
affect me like i don't sleep like
you're like okay you might not feel like
it does but
guarantee if you quantify it it just
will so
get rid of caffeine you won't need it
when you go long term johnny has a great
protocol for how to do that like without
in the most painless way by
progressively introducing more decaf
is that propanefitness.com caffeine
um and then also have a bedtime routine
so
the big problem for for workaholics like
us is that
you have open loops and you don't set
clear boundaries it's like
11 pm you're like i'll just quickly
check my email just checking there's no
like urgent stuff and then you're like
drawn in or you open
stuff that you're like oh i need to get
that done tomorrow whatever 6 p.m or 7
p.m but whenever you finish your work
day
dump everything into your capture
process and have
a plan tomorrow today habit then
shut down your computer if you want to
be a real
monster you can use cold turkey or
frozen turkey which johnny uses to just
not allow you back on your laptop until
the morning
and put your phone in a box
and then just use that evening time to
spend time with friends and family and
fully get into your body go for a walk
like have a contact switch
and basically nail the evening nail the
morning you'll sleep better
i love that that's really really good
can we get a life fails 201
we absolutely can we we've only done one
life fails episode which is just all of
this
like things that we've tried where we
[ __ ] up obviously life
life hacks is like the evolution of
things that we think are good
but they're far less entertaining than
when you tried the liquid only protein
shake diet or the
whatever it might be you know like the
million other are you going to the
bathroom again you said
i am okay can you please mute the
microphone
i'm having bladder time yeah i'll mute
thank you
how you and i always manage to go the
duration of a podcast without needing to
go to the toilet and new stuff never
manages
arabic bladders man that's what it is i
have a day off tomorrow where do i start
with your content if i am just finding
you
i think how to survive university
is a great episode the life hacks 201 is
an amazing episode
or if you want something a little bit
deeper the aubrey marcus number 117
is a [ __ ] bang uh
any tips on hunger cravings hitting my
macros but still feeling hungry and want
more
johnny fizzy water
fizzy water um if you're doing
i think when people do if it fits your
macros they start they take the mic too
much
they lose structure they lose like
consistent meal times they lose food
volume
they lose micronutrition fiber so
the danger with macros is people go so
far
people have had a meal plan and then
they think right i don't need a meal
plan i'm just going to do macros now
and that loses all the structure which
loses all of the like ingrained hunger
patterns and hunger cues so
i would suggest look at what your macros
are
build out a day of eating in
myfitnesspal have a plan for that
try and fit in like fruit and vegetables
try and fit in fibrous foods single
ingredient
unprocessed foods have some variety and
things you like but try and stick to
that as much as you can
and try and eat at the same time as much
as you can and then have like fizzy
water and stay busy
because often when people have this
problem it's because they're trying to
fit like protein pancakes and protein
syrup and quest bars and
like sugary foods in and then realizing
actually eating those things doesn't do
much of my hunger it makes thing i'm
focused on food all the time and i'm
more hungry
that's great man i just buying every
three days buying a big bag of baby
spinach and ripping it up and throwing
it into every meal
it's like the easiest yeah just add some
[ __ ] volume in there
um asda have frozen carrot and swede
mash
500 grams of carrot and swede mash and
it's
there's no calories in it 500 grams of
food
and it's about 200 cows half a kilo
volume of food and it goes with mashed
potatoes
it goes with it's not it's not potatoes
carrot and swede
um but yeah unbelievable uh if you had
to recommend
one book for someone to read what would
it be and why we can all answer this one
johnny what do you reckon can be on
anything
atomic habits probably [ __ ]
[Laughter]
was that yours yeah well it's just so
[ __ ] good man
we were talking about this on the we
were interviewed the other day about
like
what books would we recommend and
talking about reading and um
the answers i gave were like books that
are operating systems so like
atomic habits if you like you can you
apply what's in atomic habits if all you
do is apply what's in atomic habits it's
like a master level
upgrade to everything so like suddenly
everything else you're trying to do in
your life is easier or better or more
consistent
and then the same for things like the
deep workbook or digital minimalism or
getting things done
like stuff like that is like an entire
like
operating manual for us
yeah versus a lot of books are like a
single concept
that like help one thing but don't
necessarily help everything so i look
for like system level upgrades so
atomic habits would be the base of that
pyramid that's that's a really good one
um one book for someone to read
i think the forgotten highlander by
alistair erica
if no one's like it's an easy book it's
a story book basically
like real life but story book and um it
just totally reframes anyone's suffering
if you think that you're having a bad
time
read the forgotten highlander by
aleister a car and you'll realize that
you there are people out there that have
suffered more than you can possibly
believe
this guy was captured by the japanese
and basically had dysentery for five
years and built the bridge over the
river kwai
and got locked in tin boxes and then
locked on death ships and then got
knocked off his feet by the after blast
from nagasaki
and then kept quiet about it because the
army told him to for like
50 years and then wrote this is his
memoir as a call to arms for what the
japanese government had done
like just read read that book and it
will um it'll cha i think i'm going to
guess because yusuf still
muted that he's still winging uh is he
back are you back
i'm here you've done that thing again
where you've put kermit the frog behind
you
is he behind me again every whenever i'm
recording he just
i think he must live in the bathroom he
must have oh
god right you've done it get rid of him
you've done it again
this is another episode this is two
episodes in a row
do you want to make it into the trailer
well yeah for [ __ ] sake
there was a really good picture of
kermit then over
spreading his um his like pocket
but it's out the ratio is all off
oh wow i'm glad that from a quality
perspective it wasn't going to be used
for the background
um that was the reason yeah i know
pixelated yeah um what's your favorite
part of being a podcast host
giggles81 it's it's like it's so unfair
that
we all get to speak to the people that
we do like if you
asked all the different guests that
you've had on
modern wisdom and on propane fitness
propane business over the years
to spend an hour doing a one-to-one
coaching call where you're allowed to
ask them whatever you want
we would be millions of pounds in debt
but to get james clear's
time for an hour or aubry marcus or i
know for a fact aubry marcus is a couple
of grand an hour
to get him to do a coaching call like or
ben greenfield's like literally one of
the most expensive well-known coaches on
the planet
like to get these people's time and you
just get to ask them whatever you want
like oh ben my knee so my knee hurts a
little bit on the kind of on the
outside like have you got any would you
rub cbd on it
like you know you can just ask them
whatever you want um so i think that
like it is
very selfishly it's just a personal
development that's why we started the
podcast
like seriously that was the reason we
started the broken fitness part we
wanted to interview john keefer who just
released car backloading
and we got we had loads of questions
about hormone sensitive lipase and fatty
acid synthase for him
and we just called him up at what like
three in the morning for him or whatever
it was just like
john um he was like uh okay
we can talk about that masks how do you
feel about reverting to nightclub chris
when required that's to be interesting i
don't know what's happening with club
knights at the moment
um like it's just we were in
let's say we went out for dinner last
night i'm pretty certain i'm not i don't
know how
legal what we did last night was
is it that they can justify that it's
because it's a test run or it's a
practice running it's a private event
maybe
uh and had a really complete explanation
for it
i think he made it up but it was like
yeah it sounds right man
so was that the explanation it was like
um i don't know how much i can say
can i talk about it as much as i want
yeah but you don't just don't say the
name of the place in case we go okay
um like no money changed hands in this
situation
it was all like socially distanced and
there was very few people there and it
was yeah i was testing the systems
because obviously
if they were shut and then just
today opened to the public and hadn't
tested any of those processes would be a
nightmare
you're more likely to get into trouble
if you don't test it
food hygiene and also everyone yeah like
think about that
i mean so speaking of which um i went
for a burger
somewhere in yom and on the way out as i
was paying i saw they had a food hygiene
rating of zero
which i've never seen before the la
mascara
next to top top palace had that
amazing like what do you have to do to
get zero
it was quite a nice burger actually but
do you have any any symptoms
no got to waste scot-free
we've got some great questions that i've
totally missed at the bottom here
um funniest gym story from
tienen
[Applause]
i've got a bad one but i don't know if
it's even podcast appropriate fine well
i mean that that means it's definitely
podcast appropriate hit us
so i for some reason was wearing
swimming shorts
to go to the gym and they don't they
have a fly
that's just like a flap so there's no
zip
and i was going commando and it was only
when i got
back into the changing room having
finished my session
that i realized i'd like just
the old chap had popped out yeah awful
what just just kill chap and
and it was looking quite quite colorful
um shorts so i'm hoping that the
contrast won't have been
too obvious that's [ __ ] bad but like
riding the line of being put on a list
yeah being stored in a register i think
most people would
assume you'd be able to feel that but
[Laughter]
that's why it's not podcast appropriate
right
uh johnny have you got any funny stories
so it's not it didn't happen in the gym
it's also similar very similar to use of
story and it's about yousef but i
witnessed it
so it was the first competition we'd
ever been to it was a weightlifting
competition
and you're supposed to wear a singlet
and turn up in a singlet and be like you
know it's weightlifting's quite serious
there's quite a lot of rules
and yousef got on the platform to lit to
do his first
snatch or cleaning jerk in like
tracksuit bottoms and leticia's
and he was about to lift and the judge
was like whoa whoa whoa he's excuse me
like you need shorts we need to see that
you're not like wearing anything
supported underneath
so you have just took his trousers off
and he just had boxes on
i think vodafone boxes vodafone
promotional boxes bright like
fluorescent pink
and then the judge like she was says
something like are you mocking me or
something and i was like well no like
what do you want me to do like you said
take off my trousers so
and then one of the coaches um ran over
to this like
10 year old boy and just shouted out
take off your trousers take off your
truck
and like whipped his trousers off and
like gave me his little shorts or
something
and then yeah
single red light from that judge who was
already miffed obviously
but made this notch i feel like there'll
be so many of these stories if we really
sat and thought about it
lifeless let's let's let's just happen
to jim we'll do another live fails and
we'll
we'll throw through that i don't know
funniest funniest gym stories there's
like tons of stuff happens in crossfit
there's like um loads and loads of like
random things go on but
i don't tend to i don't tend to do that
many fails all that much
uh it seems like there'd be such a high
percentage of fails in crossfit because
you've got so many moving parts
such chaotic fun
i've seen people like open their heads
up on barbells or
when if you have a rig that's got
staggered height bars so you can imagine
you've got
one bar another bar above it and then a
third bar that's in the middle of those
two heights and sent out this way
if you jump onto the bottom one and face
outward
if you try and do a kipping pull up you
actually end up no no you go front of
head into the medium
medium heighted bar um which is brutal
like people doing doing workouts where
they've run out of chalk but
they're still working through stuff and
if you're doing a kipping pull-up
and you lose at the top of the kip if
you lose your grip
you're just like a cat you know like
perfectly horizontal
four feet ten feet off the ground and
you gotta try and do the
you gotta try and do like the twist
which is obviously quite challenging
i've just remembered one i can't believe
and there's a video of this
and it's it's one of the funniest videos
i've ever seen
and it's of the guy trying to spot
yourself on a bench press
of course you must have seen this chris
yousef's doing like a rap out set
and he's going like hiking spot with
blizmate and then on
every rep this guy holds on to the bar
and he's just going like
he's going no no no no
leave it right
it says like shouting at this guy every
rep
on every like it's at the point i can't
believe you've not seen this i've never
seen it it's hilarious
and then he stands up and goes cheers
mate and walks off
thank you never going to ask this guy
again he's like
and the guy re-racks the bar
voting progressively louder at him leave
it
we we have had a few of these so there's
one that there's two that's johnny's
johnny's had one is um
in david lloyd a man runs up to try and
save johnny
even though like he was he was
struggling a bit with the rep it wasn't
like
imminent danger guy runs over and he's
got like a meter of wet tissue like
coming out of his shirt and it just like
comes on johnny's face guy basically
teabags him
and it's like that's more unsafe than if
you just let him do what he's doing
i'd and the guy had like done nothing
but on my face still was his sweaty
tissue
again this is on video unbelievable the
other one
also in a david lloyd was johnny doing a
front squat with 140
um back in the day and this guy comes
over and
in a very thick south african accent
goes you're not playing
i'm sorry i say you're not playing how
much is that
and johnny's like 140. like pounds
johnny's like
yeah okay
there's also another one in a david
lloyd where i had just
missed a 230 kilo squat so like
and that's like missing after giving it
a really good try
so it's like it's a very intense
experience like very peak experience
just dumped it forward big bang stand up
and this guy goes
tell you what missed never trust a
garage
oh never trust a world
never trust a garage and then he just
tells me for five minutes this story
about how he had a bad experience with
the garage
and like his mate his mate's a mechanic
and his brother owns a garage and
i was just like [ __ ] hell like i'm
just coming i i've almost lost
consciousness
standing up just got off the phone with
the garage and just wants to just vent
to
tell somebody and now i was nearer
so this is what i mean we should it's
the sort of thing we should keep a list
of the elaborate on
a link
[Music]
it'll be on there if you want to go and
see that just watch it on youtube 1 30.
uh yousef's
yousef's found the video link and put it
in immediately
is it alfred what's the what do you
search for on alfred
leave it
[Laughter]
leave it leave it
i'm so excited to watch it chris i'm i'm
really really excited
uh best app for tracking compound lifts
gravitas you're just gonna say heavyset
and he really believes he's right but
he's wrong
yeah it depends on you so um for johnny
a few period if you're following a
periodized program gravitas
if you're just aiming for total volume
set
gravitas does an rpe based tracking as
well which is quite unique that's clever
so like you track so you can't be free
there's a free version
and it gives you loads of analytics so
like you say i did 100 kilos for five
and a nine
it calculates your estimated one right
max then tracks your estimated one rep
max over time
i'm going to download gravitas you've
opened
you've opened it in the past but really
really opened the loop
is that just to tell me i'm wrong and
the heavy sets about no i'm i'm an
open-minded guy i
you know try it
you gotta fly yeah um big big like oh
what you want kind of fly as well
what's up what's up alex
talking about a bumblebee in his in his
room
someone trying to break in and he scared
them off by going what do you want
yeah i speak like um one of the mitchell
brothers from eastenders they weren't
they weren't breaking yeah i've just
remembered
some more life fails i'm going to have
to just write this down
favorite slash most used hack ever
and first thing you're all doing
straight after lockdown
first thing i'm going to do is pick up a
barbell because i'm [ __ ]
sick of dumbbells i've only got
dumbbells in the house and i'm so
so sick of them i really just want to do
a standing straight press or a bench
press
like they're just such nice movements
it's interesting that that's the thing
you've got a craving for
like an overhead press it's desperate i
really really
really just want to do another surprise
press
i think doing a standing straight press
just an embracing of like the simple
pleasures in life
it's just so nice and simple it can't
mess it up
over head press what are you doing
first thing you're all doing straight
after lockdown first thing you're doing
after lockdown johnny
i don't know i would have said like go
for dinner we'd like to go to our
restaurant but we've done it now so
we'll go back to lockdown but maybe we
did it yeah [ __ ] it we can go back in
for another
six months anything or it was it dinner
was actually probably
like super super high on my
and last night was last night was like
four hours like the last
the final people in there as the
cleaners were coming in around us
that's the thing i really missed just
being able to spend time with lots of
people
i mean i hosted a barbecue yesterday so
that was a
you had a very very social your social
quota for
july is finished already isn't it just
used up
yeah done uh favorite slash most used
hack ever phone outside of the bedroom
for me like
it's the biggest change in life quality
uh immediately i think maybe speed up
trackpad
as well for digital stuff that's a good
one like put your trackpad speed at 100
and
and just watch your life change have we
talked about the fact that there's a
patch you can get that allows you to
take it a new spectrum
better touch tool isn't it maybe better
texture
there's a yeah there's like
it's not done by percentages either
isn't it it's just like some arbitrary
descriptor
very very fast like are you sure this
has permanent consequences
like if you put it too fast you actually
can't then disable it
because every time you try and get the
button to look at this it does have
permanent consequences it's hard
well so you wouldn't be able to move
your fingers
a small enough distance you've made the
trackpad not
not need to be this big anymore but it's
just that big
because that's all it's really doing
isn't it
frightening favorite slash most used
hack ever johnny
i don't know leave me alone
leave me alone alfred nice it's probably
something like that yeah it's all the
best ones are always as you said grace
they're always the only ones you forget
that you do
not be making making your own fizzy
water fizzy water that's
to be honest that's been a big upgrade
uh what's what's your most listened back
to
episode have you ever listened back to
much of the modern wisdom stuff
that we've done yeah it's always the
ones that
have funny moments than i can remember
so like the business 101
i think was one of the entire series i
think the business 101 is one of the
funniest episodes we've done
because all of the little little
itty-bitty stories come out like the
batteries
um it's all it's when it's when we do a
podcast and yousef says something
that we didn't know about yusuf and it's
something really
it's like the mortal kombat thing
brilliant i didn't know you did that you
have a problem you're too faceted
it's like the thing that like you
probably think about like once a
fortnight
and i have no idea yeah so that one yeah
sometimes but it's a bit weird isn't it
listening back to yourself like it's a
bit
it's a bit strange so someone linked to
me the other day to a tim ferriss
article
where he talks about he listened back to
every podcast that he did
and wrote down all of the vocal tics and
superfluous language
that he used and that's
something i do a bit i have to because
there's no one quality control checking
the audio on my end so i have to kind of
at least listen in part to every episode
just to make sure that i haven't
forgotten something that
there was a connection drop out or
something happened or whatever
so i'll listen back a fair bit but being
more deliberate with that would probably
be better for
making me a more efficient podcaster um
coming toward the end of my questions
now greatest quote that you've applied
to your life in a positive way
from jay gibson everybody want to be a
bodybuilder
but nobody wants to lift no heavy ass so
much depth in that quote
it's incredible yeah he's in like disney
ron coleman yeah
r.com have you listened to him on joe
rogan
no he just went on rogan the other week
oh really
he's a i mean he's ahead of his time
anyone who can who can approach 700
pounds on a barbell
and not take it seriously in a yellow
banana suit
as well hero i think people just don't
people don't appreciate the state of
mind that someone has to be in
to not take that seriously to get under
700 solid ass
pounds while shot while screaming
shouting death and like he's just
it's fantastic what a hero that man is
i'm doing two
i'll do two
[Laughter]
uh any more questions that you guys have
got on your side that you think are good
ones that we could finish on
we've got quite a lot so i think we
might need to do a separate one
because otherwise this podcast will go
more than two hours seven
seventy five hours how do you come up
with affirmations
find them so cheesy hard to make them
meaningful oh on the six minute diary
yeah that's a
so i'm actually doing the um love
yourself like your life depends on it
process from kamal ravikant at the
moment i've done that this year
so every day i've come up with a reason
why i'm
happy with myself proud of myself that
as opposed to it being a positive
affirmation about something
you're still having a nightmare with
that fly aren't you you sif thank you
just doing a quick internal rotation
test external rotation
yeah yeah that's fine okay we're still
there thought so i thought i had for
orange just checking
but it is it is challenging i know like
writing doing daily gratitude can
you end up sort of falling into thought
loops
but i suppose that's part of the reason
it's to get yourself out of that it's to
work out whether or not
you actually do have multiple
areas multiple things that you can sort
of use is this the gratitude section or
is this the affirmation line
so the affirmation line i think but just
the whole thing like that
i just do i think like um i can't
remember who i read this from
if you're like a self-audit like try and
pick out your weaknesses or like things
you want to improve about yourself and
then just your affirmation is just the
opposite of the thing that you
like you just consistently tell yourself
that you are like organized or whatever
and just try
try that and watch that thing what's
mental is
if you if you consistently do that the
thing that you are
trying to influence does actually change
and that's the thing that i kind of get
my head around
like i think affirmations are like
watery and don't really do anything but
if you consistently do one that's the
same thing
and target one thing i guarantee you it
improves it that's there's
two approaches in the six minute diary
isn't that there's one of them that's
like the
this spread effect and the other that's
like the chisel effect or something like
that
and that's the chisel effect you're
talking about you just keep hammering
away on the same one
the same thing yeah look we are right
we're nearly two hours in
thank you to everyone that submitted
questions sorry if we didn't get to
yours um
we'll might do it on the patreon i might
try and um
finish it up on the patreon and throw
some other stuff up there
gents 200 episodes man 200.
we made it [ __ ] hell 200 whole
episodes what a journey that's mental
uh look thank you everyone that supports
the show i
love you at the bits thank you for
tuning in 300 episodes will come in
absolutely no time if you've got any
suggestions for stuff that you want to
hear
series that you want us to do i know
that people want us to restart the
relationships one more business
principles
life fails um how to survive after uni
um but just keep you know we
we need ideas desperately
and and and food so
send us either of those send us food or
ideas or both
fizzy water water or coffee coffee and
fizzy water just not together
i've been drinking this uh 80 20 cold
brew stuff this stuff's
pretty [ __ ] good it looks a bit nitro
that looks a bit strong
no so they they do a nitro version but
it's oh do they yeah that's not that's
the original
the nitro is a bit meanwhile yusuf has
got out to the nearest sort of puddle
and scoops up some puddle water and he's
drinking that
you have looked at a coffee too you
still haven't finished it jesus christ
wow look thank you everyone for tuning
in propanefitness.com
modern wisdom if you are an online coach
who's looking to pivot your business
and if you're a coach who's looking to
pivot to online and propanefitness.com
calculator if you just want to get some
macros did i get it right
you did hey it might be the first time
as well
200 episodes and finally i got the
poster all correct
look thank you everyone for tuning in i
love you all
200 episodes is [ __ ] amazing
achievement shout out to video guy dean
who is not here but he will be doing the
edit behind the scenes
okay goodbye
[Music]